Костюм астронавта Александера Ґерста, як і
членів його команди Сергія Прокоп'єва та
Серени Ауньйон-Ченселлор, важить майже 10 кілограмів.
У космосі він забезпечує передусім дихання.
Невдовзі Ґерст вже вдруге вирушить
до міжнародної космічної станції,
однак уперше в якості командира космічного екіпажу.
Це ще той мій костюм, в якому я
минулого разу літав у космосі.
Ось навіть ще видно сліди сажі від капсули під час приземлення.
Я - один з небагатьох, кому пощастило тренуватися
у власному костюмі.
Але для наступного польоту я отримаю новий.
Він пошитий спеціально для мене і вже готовий для використання.
Такою Александер Ґерст побачив Землю
під час свого першого польоту в космос.
У 2014 році геофізик став третім німцем,
який побував на міжнародній космічній станції.
"Горизонти" – назва нової місії Ґерста.
Йдеться не лише про географічні горизонти, а й про наукові.
Заплановані близько вісімдесяти експериментів.
Деякі з них нові, інші - знайомі астронавту з попереднього польоту.
Це буде певною мірою ніби повернення додому.
Зрештою я провів там півроку свого життя
і маю дуже хороші спогади, тому я справді
дуже радію польоту.
Тренувальний центр в так званому "зоряному
містечку" неподалік Москви оповитий духом історії.
Тут тренувалися цілі покоління російських космонавтів
та західних астронавтів.
Нині до "підкорення космосу" готується ці троє астронавтів.
Аби політ 6 червня пройшов без проблем, вони
тренують у капсулі "Союз" старт,
посадку та стиковку із міжнародною космічною станцією.
У центрі управління польотом російські фахівці
щодня імітують до дванадцяти імовірних проблем.
Кожна з них може коштувати команді життя,
якщо її не розпізнають і не усунуть вчасно.
Цей етап тренування - найскладніший, зізнаються астронавти.
Він потребує найвищої концентрації та швидкої реакції.
Зрозуміло, що ризик не нульовий.
Він, звісно, вищий, ніж якщо їхати кудись потягом.
Але ми летимо не заради розваги, ми проводимо
наукові експерименти, дослідження, які стануть в пригоді людству.
І для мене це те, заради чого я готовий ризикувати.
Через сорок років після польоту першого німця
у космос Александер Ґерст вирушає до
міжнародної космічної станції
як перший німецький командир екіпажу.
Це - завдання, до якого він ретельно готується
у російському "зоряному містечку".